[Música]
y
frank pascual
[Aplausos]
os voy a contar mi historia con los
videojuegos es un tema bastante polémico
todo el mundo tiene una opinión hay
gente que dice que los videojuegos son
el demonio alejemos a nuestros hijos de
ellos hay gente que dice que los
videojuegos son el santo grial de la
educación que están muy bien yo ni una
cosa ni la otra
os voy a contar mi historia desde el
principio padre informático madre
informática hijo gamer no quedaba no
quedaba otra era de cajón mis padres
siempre cuentan anécdotas sobre cómo
incluso antes de aprender a hablar yo ya
sabía utilizar un ordenador esto es
verdad el periódico puede ser que hoy en
día pues oye no tenga mucho mérito
porque los niños nacen pegados a una
consola y a un móvil a una tablet pero
oye yo era del 97 y para mi época pues
tiene su mérito supongo que no todos los
que estáis aquí soy jugones o sois
gamers o estáis en el mundo de los
videojuegos así que os voy a introducir
un poquito
existen un tipo de juegos a lo que los
jugones le llamamos agujeros negros le
llamamos agujeros negros porque estos
juegos te absorben la vida son juegos
como world of warcraft como league of
legends yo tengo una teoría como podéis
ver no se me dan muy bien las
matemáticas ni el dibujo es lo máximo
que puedo hacer y es que yo pienso que
existe una relación inversa perfecta
entre lo bien que te va en un videojuego
y lo bien que te va en la vida real os
pongo un ejemplo para que lo comprendáis
nivel 67 en el world of warcraft una
semana sin salir de tu casa si esto
funciona así
además otra de mis pasiones desde
pequeñito siempre he hecho atletismo
no sé si conocéis la diferencia entre un
atleta y un runner
mientras los atletas se dedican a correr
los runners se dedican a comprarse cosas
para correr yo yo era un atleta yo era
un atleta pero tengo que decir que con
el tiempo me fui convirtiendo en un
runner esto es verdad pero bueno era un
poco legítimo porque la intensidad de
mis entrenamientos y la intensidad de
las competiciones también está
aumentando entonces es legítimo empecé a
comprarme muchos pares de zapatillas iba
al fisio iba al nutricionista o en
etcétera etcétera un día después de una
competición yo tenía 16 años y me notaba
raro me notaba raro y vale mi decisión
es normal has competido puede que estés
cansado no no era eso pasa una cosa con
los atletas no sé si alguno de vosotros
corre pero nos conocemos mucho porque
siempre estamos mirando uy pues el
gemelo me duele este ejercicio muy
posible esto no me sienta bien esto me
sienta mal y yo sería me encontraba raro
bueno lo dejé pasar fuimos a cenar fui
con mi familia etcétera a celebrar que
había ganado
llegué a casa no sé si lo estoy notando
pero yo soy una persona muy nerviosa
entonces pues me cuesta dormir me tardé
mucho en dormirme y odio bueno pues es
normal
vomité una vez estando ya en casa bueno
normal me puede haber sentado mal la
comida
vomité dos vomité 3,64 vomité cinco no
hace falta tener un sexto sentido para
saber que si vomita seis veces algo está
pasando me levanté fui a despertar a mis
padres corriendo al hospital en llegar
al hospital médico cansado médico de las
cuatro de la mañana médico de guardia
nada contra los médicos el médico me
empezó a contar una historia sobre que
yo había girado el cuerpo y entonces
pues puede ser que se me hubiese
inflamado la lumbar mira que es difícil
convencer a una madre sobre la salud de
su hijo pero mi madre se quedó
convencida dijo bueno puede ser yo no yo
no me quedé convencido pero no no es la
cosa de ir al médico ir de listo y
decirlo yo por qué tienes que hacer esto
no eso nunca sale bien entonces pues yo
le fui dejando y seguro que una
analítica no y seguro que al final me
hizo una analítica siguiente capítulo
yo estaba ingresado en la uci
insuficiencia renal aguda mi riñón
derecho pues había dejado
funcionar ha dicho hasta aquí
yo estaba ingresado y dj frank estarías
mal estaba en la uci aún me dirás
estaría en mal no estaría fatal
vomitando llorando oye pues yo estaba
feliz porque también soy una persona muy
cabezota entonces tenía razón me podía
morir pero me podía morir con razón que
no es lo mismo más recuerdo cada vez que
pasaba el médico yo estaba llorando en
la habitación vomitado
lo sabía lo sabía y hasta el micof esto
es verdad verídico no mentira ya sabéis
cómo funcionan las cosas de hospital la
cosa va lenta al final me subiera una
planta tenía un compañero de habitación
bastante majo la verdad un día estábamos
viendo la tele estamos viendo la
película sin límites no sé si os suena
límites pues algún bilingüe en la sala
la película trata sobre un escritor que
vaya por dios no vende mucho no le va
muy bien en la vida le va fatal y un día
su cuñado le presenta una pastilla él
dice mira tío si te tomas esta pastilla
vas a llevar tu cerebro al siguiente
nivel al siguiente nivel cognitivo se la
toma y empieza a ver cómo su vida cambia
empieza a ver cómo empieza a aprender
idiomas empieza a conocer gente nueva le
va súper bien en el trabajo etcétera yo
estaba en el hospital me giro y le digo
a mi padre yo quiero yo quiero ser eso
claro lo que pasa que empecé a
investigar empecé a investigar y me di
cuenta que la organización mundial de la
salud había propuesto incluir el
trastorno por adicción a los videojuegos
en la clasificación internacional de
enfermedades
claro yo dije pues oye voy a investigar
a ver la gente que dice si está a favor
está en contra la industria de los
videojuegos os podéis imaginar no le
hacía mucha gracia a la cosa está pero
dijo pues voy a preguntar a los
psicólogos yo estudio psicología y estoy
en tercero no lo dicho hasta ahora y
digestivos voy a preguntarle a mi
profesor no voy a decir su nombre por si
se cabrea vamos a llamarlo pepito le
pregunté a pepito le dije oye qué
opinión tenéis los psicólogos sobre el
trastorno por adicción a los videojuegos
y me dijo mira frank pasa una cosa y es
que si aceptamos el trastorno por
adicción a los videojuegos que será lo
siguiente el trastorno por adicción al
chocolate que nos quita criterio nos
quita criterio además con ese profesor
yo había gustado había estado durante un
año entero intentando de demostrar que
existía la adicción al azúcar etcétera
bueno yo teníamos una pelea y los dos al
final me dijo que no me fui a investigar
por mí mismo y encontré que era
organización mundial de la salud
proponían tres criterios clave yo lo
miré y dije yo cumplo los 3
falta de control claro yo recuerdo a mi
madre entrando en la habitación y
decirme de frank llevas seis horas
jugando en mamá me acabo de poner no no
sé si esto yo era consciente o se lo
decía porque me dejara jugar pero lo
hacía el segundo criterio era prioridad
de jugar frente a otras actividades
por aquel entonces mi vida se dividía en
dos categorías una categoría las cosas
que incluían jugar otra categoría las
cosas que no incluían jugar los pongo un
ejemplo mis padres me decían frank vamos
a ir al campo están los primos vamos a
hacer barbacoa bien violencias no caca
sin embargo mis padres me decían frank
vamos ir al campo están los primos la
barbacoa y el primo se va a llevar la
consola bien eso sí eso era bien el
tercer criterio diagnóstico es la
continuación a pesar de consecuencias
negativas qué consecuencias negativas
oye pues todo lo que hemos jugado
videojuegos sabemos que cuando llevan
mucho tiempo jugando entras en un estado
de mal rollo de ansiedad que no mola
mucho
lo que pasó es que ahora me estáis
diciendo vale frank nos ha soltado todo
este rollo no me convence bueno pues
vamos a ir un poquito más sabéis lo que
es esto salió es dopamina es dopamina a
nivel fisiológico cuando jugamos a los
videojuegos liberamos dopamina también
cuando corremos y esto lo que nos hace
es volver a jugar otra vez bueno no está
mal no es la causa principal del
trastorno pero puede ayudar
ahora en cuanto a los factores
psicológicos tiene más chicha la cosa
dos características claves de los juegos
que te hacen volver a jugar a ellos de
hecho durante la charla yo está hablando
sobre juegos en general pero yo jugaba
un tipo de juegos que se llaman juegos
de rol son juegos de rol porque entras a
un nuevo mundo un nuevo rol y abandonas
tu vida la primera característica de
este tipo de juegos es que alimentan tu
ego alimentan tubo como estáis viendo
constantemente los desarrolladores lo
saben entonces están dando premios te
dicen oye pues sube de nivel pues has
conseguido este objeto pues traspasar
esta mazmorra pues ha llegado este tal
pero en realidad estás en tu casa
delante de una pantalla el otro criterio
es que te ayudan a evadirse de la
realidad a unos niveles impresionantes
claro yo cuando vi esto dije volviendo a
la historia dije tengo que empezar a
cambiar y como empecé a cambiar elegir
tres áreas de mi vida para empezar a
cambiar la primera fue la alimentación
empecé a investigar y saber por qué hay
dietas que son mejores que otras el
azúcar si el azúcar no lactosa sin
lactosa no no lo sé empecé a investigar
la segunda faceta que empecé a atacar
fue habilidades sociales
durante toda la charla parece que está
demonizando a los videojuegos pero no es
así yo pienso que si tú juegas de forma
patológica a un videojuego refleja
problemas en la persona externos al
videojuego
por aquel entonces yo tenía un problema
muy muy muy grave que era que no se me
daba muy bien las habilidades sociales y
por eso empecé a atacarlas y empecé a
ver cambios instantáneos y la tercera la
tercera faceta fue el desarrollo
personal me metí en el desarrollo
personal porque quería saber por qué
unas personas les iban mejor que otras
porque unas personas tenían más éxito
que otras oye porque la autoestima
porque el ego etcétera empecé a
investigar en este mundo bueno y después
de este rollo a lo mejor pasado mañana
no os acordáis de nada no os acordáis de
mi vida me da igual está bien pero
quiero que os llevéis algo no me parece
justo entonces quiero que llevéis esto y
es que nadie os tiene que dar permiso
que tiene que pagar mejor no tiene nada
que ver con lo dicho pues sí que tiene
que ver lo que yo me di cuenta es que
las personas cuando tenemos una vida que
no nos gusta pero no las cambiamos
parece que estamos a la espera de que
venga alguien se alineen los astros se
acerca y nos diga ahora puedes también y
eso nunca pasa nunca nunca nunca va a
ser el momento perfecto entonces si
queréis empezar a cambiar daos permiso
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]